je passe un bon moment fric est une
tempête pour le vrai pourquoi on habite
maintenant à un recul un peu ya la plus
âpre également je peux pas toi recul des
amis cela nous allait bien que passer de
bonnes vacances vous faites les zigotos
en colo au travail à l'école en faisant
vos devoirs je sais pas si vous faites
écouter nous on est au canada avec
clément vous savez sûrement parce que je
me suis sûr que vous êtes des gens bien
parce que j'ai posté deux photos je
crois ou trois pas beaucoup mais un peu
quand même qu'est ce qu'on fout au
canada et au québec plus
particulièrement et ben écoutez l'office
du tourisme du canada nous a invités ici
pendant une semaine pour faire plein
d'activités de ouf à travers trois
régions du québec l'a mauvaise et bonne
nouvelle quand même parce que ça fait
des bonnes vidéos c'est que les blocs
sortiront en septembre et par 91 déçu
c'est normal
un gros but je me prends pour une faute
de courage de cette vidéo pour vous
prévenir du coach canada déclare je m'en
vais à toronto prononcé jour en avons
vraiment vacances on s'est fait un
tatouage au canada regardez par david
côté
j'étais un vrai bonhomme j'ai pas du
tout souffert petites anecdotes drôles
j'ai découvert son talent grâce à
clément ici présent et je savais pas
mais en fait c'est avoir préféré de mon
frère mon frère lie toutes ses photos
sur instagram ne soit pas dégoûté
florent ça va aller david a pensé à toi
mec il m'a donné un petit tatouage
temporaire que je pourrais te prêter
allègrement qui d'ailleurs ne peut plus
marcher maintenant vous qui vient de
prendre 100 grammes de plus de sue voilà
les amis c'est tout pour les news vous
souhaite de brommat quand je vous dis à
dans une semaine environ vous me
connaissez j'ai pas vous quittez là
dessus je suis pas fdp qui joue ici sur
un petit extrait du tout ce qu'on a pu
faire au québec
en sept jours je le rappelle les vidéos
sortir en septembre et je vous dis à
bientôt je mens mais n'est pas trop loin
quand même parce qu'il pleut sous cet
arbre que l'être humain génial ses
joueurs
[Musique]
non